je passe la parole au président russe
vladimir poutine
madame la présidente chers collègues
avant tout comme les autres participants
à notre forum je voudrais remercier nos
partenaires néo zélandais pour
l'organisation de notre forum
d'aujourd'hui l'actualité exceptionnelle
de sujets qui a été retenu a été noté
par tous les intervenants
je suis complètement d'accord avec les
collègues qu'il faut agir ensemble en
réunissant nos soutenons le projet du
document de notre sommet qui vise à
l'interaction coordonnées dans le cadre
de l'apec dans la lutte contre la
pandémie
malheureusement la situation
épidémiologique dans le monde reste
difficile ce qui a été remarqué par nos
collègues y compris les pas et les
collègues de l'om est ce bien sûr aucun
pays n'est protégé contre cette pandémie
et il s'agit de la distribution
équitable des vaccins et des tests tout
à l'heure le collègue en a parlé et
compte tenu des risques élevés
nous croyons que la priorité c'est
l'élargissement de la vaccination et
nous sommes prêtes à la coopération
étroite avec les partenaires de l'apec
dans l'organisation de la vaccination
massive de la population y compris des
migrants de travail
le rétablissement de ceux qui ont été
malades en russie nous avons conçu
quatre vaccins contre
le corps n'avait eu ce sont les vaccins
sécurisé et fiable la haute qu'elle
était du premier vaccin contre le coc
vide spoutnik venait confirmer apparaît
presque soixante dix et à qui on a
approuvé l'utilisation de ce vaccin n o
menons la promotion de la localisation
de la production de ce vaccin et grâce à
la coopération avec certaines industries
dans les pays de l'apec nous avons
conclu des accords de la fabrication de
ce vaccin pour le montant de 800
millions de doses nous croyons qu'il
faut développer la production des
vaccins et éliminer les barrières qui
empêchent la fabrication des vaccins
puisque lé rythme des vaccinations et la
fonction de la relance et économique
pour minimiser les risques et qui sont
dus à des nouvelles voix rauque et
surmonter les tendances négatives dans
le social lui est la pandémie a frappé
est tous les membres de l'apec dans nos
pays
le nombre de comptes ni contaminés
remonte à 53 millions et 1,4 million
sont morts et bien sûr le pib s'est
contracté de 1,9 pour cent nous avons
réalisé tout un ensemble de mesures en
russie pour protéger les entreprises
minimiser les risques et soutenir les
industries les plus touchés et ce qui
nous a permis de relancer la croissance
et je voudrais dire que les conséquences
de la pandémie sont surmontés en russie
l économie se rétablit et nous sommes
prêts à partager notre expérience
par exemple dans le cadre du dialogue
ministériel
au sein de l'apec dans le contexte de la
pandémie il faut parler de la
coopération entre les pays qui est de
l'asie pacifique dans le numérique c'est
très important parce que aujourd'hui les
collègues en ont parlé nous proposons
deux une vision plus large dans le
numérique en parlant des réformes des
technologies de l'information dans la
santé dans l'éducation dans le social il
faut protéger les pertes de données
personnelles il faut continuer la
réalisation de la feuille de route dans
le numérique l'économie numérique un
ensemble avec les entreprises avec la
population la société et le conseiller
économique de l'apec
on est intéressé et pour le faire pour
créer d'ici 2040 la société transparente
dans notre région nous avons besoin de
milieux transparent dans le domaine des
affaires
la russie contribue à ce processus et ce
forum à contribuer à ce processus
bien sûr cela devrait se passer dans le
cadre de toutes les normes sanitaires
le forum économique de saint-pétersbourg
en est la preuve
en marge de ce forum nous avons signé
environ 800 contrats commerciaux et nous
espérons que les représentants des
grandes économies de la région vont
participer au forum orientale qui se
tiendra en septembre en russie et en
terminant je voudrais souhaiter à la
nouvelle zélande beaucoup de succès en
tant que présidente de la pec suivre
merci
j league actuelle est finie
[Musique]